Wow
[Music]
I'm looking forward to doing this I
think it's gonna be a lot of fun because
the kids are gonna be included in this
video
that we're doing in them I always like
to see the looks on their faces doing
something that I'm sure that they
haven't ever done before that's cool for
me being involved in this is all really
good but but getting to share it with
the kids is really the best part what I
noticed about working with the kids who
are patients at Shriners is that as and
it's really embodied in these kids here
is that they're they really understand
what it's like to embrace life and enjoy
all the good things that life has to
offer I think in in this video I don't
want to give too much away but I'm kind
of acting like things are
inconveniencing me small things in life
and I'm not aware as I should be about
what life can hand you and and I think
that when you have you know trouble
times in your life when especially with
a health issue to be able to see the
bright side and enjoy life is is really
important that's what these guys make me
think
and like all the kids I saw when I was
in st. Louis as well it's just a song
that everyone knows it's a song that
everyone loves to sing when the song
comes on you just can't help but just
start pouring your soul into the song so
it's gonna be a lot of fun and I can't
wait I'm really honored that I could
sing something like this for such a big
national campaign and I've been singing
for years and it's always been a dream
to be recognized and to sing one
foreigner song as it's been donated to
my hospital two of the most important
things to me are Shriners and being able
to sing
Shriners have been a presence had so
many of our shows for so many years
seeing these guys with the funny hats we
still haven't got to have yeah and
together you know we're working and
raising money and it's just so funny
kind of how it works and and when I made
a trip to the Shriners Hospital in st.
Louis there were a couple guys in the
lobby there was a couple Shriners guys
and they were just hanging out and I
just got this sense that they're they're
always around and they're always there
just ready to help and it's such a
seemingly casual but when you start
looking into it you see how much this
organization does